بدايه اشكر الله سبحانه وتعالى على النجاح
والتوفيق نهنئ القياده ونبارك لهم نجاح
الاطلاق وارسال اول رائده فضاء سعوديه
وعربيه ومسلمه واول رائد فضاء سعودي الى
محطه الفضاء الدوليه نبارك للوطن بكل فخر
واعتزاز هذا الانجاز التاريخي في خدمه
الوطن والعلم والانسانيه وصدقا لم يكن هذا
الانجاز ليتحقق لولا الدعم الكبير
والتمكين من سمو سيدي ولي العهد رئيس
المجلس الاعلى للفضاء قبل عده اسابيع
التقى برواد الفضاء واكرمهم بكلمات ملهمه
ومحفزه هي وقود الحماس والشغف لدى رواد
الفضاء لما اطلعوا لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
هذه المهمه هي احدى برامج
رواد الفضاء في تبع الخطه السنويه تبع
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للفضاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم في رصيد المملكه
ثلاث رواد الفضاء فيصير ترتيبنا في على
مستوى جد مجموعه العشرين التاسع ونحن
الاول على مستوى المنطقه في عدد رواد
الفضاء الذين صعدوا الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه دكتور ما هو الهدف من هذه المهمه
الحقيقه رواد الفرج يقوم بعده تجارب علميه
عددها 14 تجربه علميه وطبيبيه من اهمها
احدى التجار برفع الكفاءه علاج السرطان
والامراض المزمنه بالشراكه مع مستشفى
الملك فيصل التخصصي والثاني تجربه جدا
مهمه ولاول مره تقام على محطه الفضاء
الدوليه وهي لرفع كفاءه تقنيه الاستمطار
ولها فائده الفائده الاولى لرفع تقنيات
الاستمطار على الارض ومعالجه التحديات
البيئه على الارض والثانيه ايضا لدراسه
امكانيه الاستمرار على الكواكب الاخرى
وهذه التجربه والشراكه مع جامعه الملك فهد
والبترول والمعادن من ولايه فلوريدا من
مقر اطلاق الصاروخ الذي انطلق قبل قليل
اكرر تهنئه للقياده وبارك للوطن وبارك
لعائله ريان برناوي وعائلتي على نجاح
الاطلاق
واتمنى لهم وصولا سالمة للمحطه الفضائيه
الدوليه ونجاح في التنفيذ تجاربهم العلميه
ويعودون باذن الله سالمين الى ارض الوطن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات